6 23 it's Tuesday Morning the second
annual tag Global Spirit awards are
coming up later this month right here in
the valley yeah this is exciting and to
Mark the occasion we are joined by the
awards co-founder Master mixologist I
mean you're like a guru of cocktails
Tony abuganum also the modern mixologist
and we are so excited to have you here
today first let's talk about this big
event that's going on that people can
take part in absolutely Heather thank
you it's the second annual we kick off
on Sunday January 29th with the cocktail
competition featuring six MGM properties
sponsored by Woody Creek it's called the
Lion's Den all right oh it's gonna be
held at the old Bank nightclub inside
Bellagio it's open to everyone please
come out and cheer on your favorite then
we go to Monday Monday we do our
educational track over at the Delano
Monday night at Cleaver
we have a dinner then dinner is Tuesday
and Wednesday and then it all ends on
Friday with the pink Thai Gala up at
Skyfall and just to give people an idea
of you know this is isn't just a bunch
of people getting around to just drink a
bunch of awesome uh that's fantastic too
but what is the sort of goal of an event
like this well really at the foundation
is a spirit's competition so you enter
your Brands they're judged by a panel of
global judges from four continents to
get best of show which we have a best of
show winner from last year the city was
Reposado tequila it was best to show in
the reposado category and when I thought
we'd do today yeah some fun have a
little our own competition yes don't you
think John are you ready I'm ready for
it if this goes as well as the cooking
competition I'm in good shape Tony what
are we making all right we're gonna make
Palomas this is a drink we feature at
libertine social we're going to start
off by squeezing half a lime right into
the glass we're going to build this a la
minute okay the drink I discovered in
Guadalajara in 1999 I brought it back to
Las Vegas to the Bellagio and like I
said featured drink at libertine social
inside Mandalay Bay okay all right now a
pinch of that sea salt goes right into
the glass John if you want to grab that
Reposado and we can start working no I
think I'm going to keep it here
just drizzle in about two ounces two
ounces yeah okay I've never been the
best with measuring well that's okay I
mean I think I'm strong if you like a
real Paloma that looks good so Tony I
actually studied abroad in Guadalajara a
little bit after that so I became a big
fan of the Paloma but what I noticed is
it always tastes better in Mexico well
that's because of the Mexican squirt
it's sweetened with pure cane sugar and
not high fructose corn syrup like it is
in the United States so it's good here
but it's even better we've got about a
minute left what else we gotta do we're
going to go ahead and top that with the
Mexican squirt okay so we'll just go
ahead and fill that up you have a modern
mixologist 24 degree bar spoon I think
mine actually I'm you know don't judge
me Tony you're in it for the win Heather
okay so I go this way well you generally
it's the other way but uh
okay all right all right now the spent
lime it goes in as the garnish oh okay
all right and just the way they drink
them in Guadalajara right here I'm not
waiting for him cheers Breakfast of
Champions here uh Tony thanks for coming
in this morning good job tag Spirit
Awards and you've got yourself a little
whiskey right there so we're we're
getting going here sorry Tony we're
gonna put all this information folks on
the website so that you can go out you
can enjoy some good drinks and say hi to
Tony yeah I love it all right thank you